- You mentioned about
Sweden, Finland, the Nordics,
why is that interesting to you?
- To me, why it's interesting?
- Yeah.
- What would you do here?
- Yeah so I've spent a lot
of time in Stockholm as well.
- Yeah.
- You know, I guess the way
I think about the world is if
you lay out the world in a flat
map there are clearly 8, 10, 15
regions one could argue that
they want to put a flag if they
want to be global.
- Yeah.
- Very simply, I couldn't
imagine trying to achieve my
ambitions of building global
brands without having a presence
in the Nordics.
I think it's enough of its own
micro culture within a European
landscape that it's, first of
all, I've been to between Sweden
and Finland I've been in the
region 9, 10 times already.
There's a comfort zone.
I like the people.
I like the DNA of the, I like
the blend of, first of all, I'm
a hard-core hustler for American
so no part of the world is gonna
work as hard but, you know,
there's some parts of Europe
that don't work at all,
by my standards.
I like the work ethic,
innovation, culture aspects of
the Nordic as a whole and so
very simply it is on the list of
those 10 regions like
South America, like Asia,
like Western Europe that I just
know that I will be.
- Hard working and tech savvy.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just
enough business-oriented.
The things I fear are not, you
know, Germany's a good example.
It's a great amazing innovation
but so much infrastructure,
very difficult to
do business in.
Especially things I care about.
If you listen, I don't
know if you heard my talk.
- [Gabrielle] Yeah, I did.
- Hire fast, fire faster. Right?
Not very good in Germany
when you have six months.
- [Gabrielle] Sweden either.
- Correct.
I am aware so that you know
remember I said self-awareness?
I know how I like running
businesses so I need to be
careful where I set up shop
because for not only the people
but what are the
government restrictions?
What's the playing field but
I feel a merit, listen, at the
end of the day, most of European
rules are a little bit more
difficult for my fire fast
higher fast so that becomes
an even playing field.
The other thing that's gonna
play out for me is as my profile
as a businessman continues to
grow there will inevitably be
places that the people
that I've more fans.
More people interested in me
being in so one of the reasons
I come to something like this
is I want awareness in the
marketplace and now over next
six months I'll be very careful
to watch my numbers of
consumption of my
content in Finland.
What kind of emails I get,
what kind of business
development things I get.
Same way I look at
Sweden and Norway and Poland.
- [Gabrielle] You can
follow it all exactly because
you have all the data.
- Correct.
- [Gabrielle] Fantastic.
- And so, you know as I was
saying to David before I'm like
there's not a lot of things
that I do for kicks and giggles.
Even though I am a very
casual guy, I'm very serious and
strategic about what I do in my
life and so I'm very optimistic.
- [Gabrielle] Even going out
to dinner tonight seemed like a
thought through--
- Listen, I don't want to,
listen, as much as I like to
paint myself as a genius, you
know you got to eat dinner and
I want to see Dick and things
but I'll say this Gabrielle even
this interview why I always
yes, I'm a big believer in the
following statement.
People make the world.
- [Gabrielle] Mhmmm.
- And for me I like
people naturally.
People like me naturally and
maybe something, you know
my PR team is always mad at me.
I'll do some little blog,
I'll do an interview and then
I'll say no to CNN or
Wall Street Journal and they're
always like no you have to do
better time management and
I don't think they understand.
Yes, more people will read about
me in those places but the depth
of people you can only do one on
one, one on two, one on four and
so I'm always trying to put
myself in a position where I'm
learning and meeting new people
because you know we may do
something together
35 years from now.
- [Gabrielle] Who knows?
- Who knows?
- What would it look like if you
set up shop in
Sweden like in London.
- Yes.
- Give me a feel
for what it would--
- I would take 5 to 6 people
from the New York
office and bring them.
I have a lot of young people
who want to travel the world.
Very important to me
to have that culture.
I would then hire three or four
people from the market that knew
of me or VaynerMedia so they
really knew what they
were getting into.
We would start with
those 7, 8, 10 people.
We would be very strategic about
having a client or
two in the market.
I met the head of marketing
from FinnAir and I said
hey, can I have your card.
I want to have a client or two
in the marketplace and then we
would set up shop and I would
come over often and I would try
to do media and interviews to
build up the profile but at the
end of the day it
would be about the work.
London is working.
I did a good job promoting we
got good people but the only
reason next year looks healthy
is the people that hired us are
blown away by the work.
They tell somebody else.
At the end of the day, no
marketing, no charismatic leader
trumps being good at your craft
and so the number one thing
would be who are the 10 people a
mix of original Vayner employees
and a mix of the Swedes or the
Finns or wherever it is that
could actually know what to
do in this market or in the
Stockholm market better than
anybody that anybody else could
hire and we're obsessed
with the quality of the work.
- [Gabrielle] I have a
conservative leadership of
people who run
all the companies.
What's your message?
Why should they hire you?
What's your...?
- The truth is, I think
you'll find this interesting.
I'm not so compelled to
say they should hire me.
What's way more interesting for
me is if they believe in what
I believe in they'll naturally
be interested in what I do.
Which is the world's changing.
I mean, you know, I think
people take things for granted.
How are we
recording this interview?
You're doing it
through your telephone.
Do you know how crazy that is if
you talked about
that 15 years ago?
People don't understand how big
this is and so I think the thing
I would say conservative leaders
and we have 'em the US as well
is look if you're not looking at
how you're doing your business
every day and trying to say is
this smart for the world we live
in today because 2016 is already
very different then 2009
and it feels like yesterday.
- [Gabrielle] Mhmmm.
- Right?
I mean 2009 all three of us,
well none of us here are that
old, I'm probably the oldest
but 2009 feels like
I don't know yesterday.
Seven years ago you have leaders
that are 50, 60, 70 years old
in these companies and 1984
and 1975 feels like yesterday.
- [Gabrielle] 10 years
ago yeah, there was no Facebook.
- That's right and so and
and go back 15 years and
nobody had a smartphone.
I mean, most of our
communication in
Sweden is through text.
And people didn't text 15
years ago, 20 years ago.
So, I just don't think people
understand, so I think the
number one thing I would say to
the conservative leadership is
I'm a businessman not a
social media enthusiast.
I think you need to look at
your profit and loss, your P&amp;L.
- [Gabrielle] Yeah.
- And you need to think about
what you're spending money on
and if you're not spending
enough money on things that are
happening in this device to
drive your business results,
that's something that
needs to be challenged.
- [Gabrielle] Let's say you
weren't, you get the message--
- Yes.
- I'm doing it
right, how do I start?
I don't really get this stuff.
- I think as I said in the room,
I think you spend the
20 to 50 hours as a
leader to educate yourself.
There's a site called Google and
a site called YouTube that you
can type in unbelievable amounts
of words and they will give you
unbelievable free information
which then, in my opinion,
allows you to
make a senior hire.
You know I'm worried about?
I'm always worried that when
I talk, 'cause I'm motivational,
people get excited and then
I'm scared they're gonna hire
somebody to be their head of
social media but they themselves
don't understand it and
that's a bad situation.
So what I would say
is educate yourself.
Know what this is, then make a
smart hire because you know and
then build a
department around it.
- But if you Google it I imagine
you'd find an incredible amount
of good advice too.
- Good and bad, right?
- Good and bad, yeah.
You go to put in the work.
If you own a business or
if you're the CEO of a big
business, you've gotta put in
the 50 hours of reading and
listening and watching.
It's like anything else you
had to learn how to drive.
You had to learn how to walk.
You have to put in the work.
- Now you got to learn
how to use Snapchat.
- Yes, right and it is a funny
way of saying you have to know
how the world is communicating.
You can't just show up and not
understand the shift and again
like a been saying the
biggest problem is it's so big.
This is big.
What you and I, we're
lucky the three of us.
The last 60 years were the same.
Radio, television,
newspaper, it was the same.
You have to go back to
ancestors that weren't,
aren't alive anymore.
If you and I and DRock and
everybody watching had our
great, great, great,
great-grandmother here
she would explain.
She would say yes then they
invented the radio and we used
you know or the telephone
like this has happened before.
There were people who
lived without a telephone.
They wrote letters.
Yes and when the telephone
came, go read the articles.
Western Union said that the
telephone was a fad and would be
gone in three years.
- There's a Swedish minister who
said the internet was a fad too.
That's very famous.
- I know what
you're referring to.
- Speaking of which,
let's bring in politics.
- Okay.
- Or politics to business is
politics understanding something
that business isn't?
Is it different or similar?
- No, I think it's the same.
There're unbelievable amounts of
politicians that don't believe
in this and then occasionally
you have some that do and
they're benefiting and it's not
just Donald Trump that people
want to refer to.
There are 25-year-old,
30-year-old mayors all across
America that have won because
they went on Facebook and their
50-year-old competitor tried
to do a television and signs.
It's happening.
- [Gabrielle] Interesting.
- It's happening in
all walks of life.
Nonprofits, Charity: Water,
Pencils of Promise, they were
small charities, now they've
become big charities 'cause
they're playing here and
big charities are
playing the old world.
- [Gabrielle] I want to go
back to politics but first,--
- Please.
- [Gabrielle] Any
specific field that is
particularly interesting?
Do you see
something in charities
or something in churches?
- As far as somebody
doing good or bad?
- [Gabrielle] Interesting stuff.
- I think the most interesting
stuff to me right now is media
companies that sell traditional
media spending money on this
new media to drive their
business to sell old media.
Think about that.
You have television and
newspaper companies spending a
lot of money on social media to
get people to read to then sell
companies to buy
print and commercials.
- [Gabrielle] It is
very interesting.
Makes me think of Amazon,
Jeff Bezos for some reason.
I guess modern buying old.
- Stores you mean?
Oh, by the way,
let's talk about that.
That's so weird I almost brought
that up in the other room.
I think the two of the
best business deals that have
happened in the last 10 years is
the person Jeff Bezos buying the
Washington Post and I don't
remember who bought the
Boston Globe but it was
an entrepreneur.
Very inexpensive.
- [Gabrielle] Sure.
- Here's why.
Not because I believe in the
newspaper model but I believe
that the brand is very valuable.
- [Gabrielle] And you
believe in content.
- Always but brand.
The Boston Globe and The
Washington Post are brands and
for the 35, 40 million
if you make that brand.
When he bought the Washington
Post a lot of people asked me
why did Bezos buy it.
I said if you open your Kindle
if he would've won the game.
For example, if Apple bought the
Wall Street Journal and every
time you turned on your phone,
Wall Street Journal would be the
front page of the Wall Street
Journal would be and you'd have
to swipe and start,
it would be the most important
media company in the world.
- [Gabrielle] Interesting.
- So it's when you,
Marvel comic books as a
comic book company it was crap.
But the people that bought it
made movies and it went from
being bankrupt to
being worth billions.
- [Gabrielle] Like a Star Wars.
Very interesting.
- IP.
- [Gabrielle] Let's go
back to politics, who's--
- Sure.
- what do you think of the
current Clinton versus Trump?
I mean Trump is doing
thing on Twitter for sure.
- Yeah, I think Donald Trump has
activated social in a way that
people didn't understand and has
benefited greatly and I think
that neither one of
them are doing a good job.
- Why not?
- Because they're both
really full of shit.
Meaning they're, the best way to
do social if you're a politician
is to prove that it's you.
More vid, both of them should
be doing unbelievable amounts of
Facebook video and of
Periscope and things of that
nature but they're behind the
written word, you can look,
I know when Donald's tweeting
as Donald and when
it's his team doing it.
- Yeah.
- Hillary is a machine.
It's all not her and so I think
the great thing about social is
that authenticity and I think
that as well as Donald's doing
if he or if she would
do a lot more video.
For example,
I just gave this talk.
I was looking at
people saying nice things.
I replied in video form.
That person knows it's me.
They don't have to guess if it's
my intern, if it's somebody back
in the States and that depth is
a connection and so I think the
great miss of politicians is not
to use more video and audio and
that's why I would say that
they're not using it
as well as they could.
- Because they're scared.
They want control.
- Of course and they want scale.
- Yeah.
- So if--
- You can get scale, can't you?
- You can get scale if your
interns are tweeting for you.
It's harder for you to do it.
- Alright.
- But I think when Hillary's on
the way to her next event, in
the 10 minutes she's in the car
she should be videoing 10 people
because it scales.
Taylor Swift does this
extremely well as a pop star.
She does a lot of engagement.
She shows up at
people's weddings.
It's not a good use of Taylor
Swift's time to show up to
somebody's wedding
that they said,
"Taylor, can stop
by my wedding," but it is.
Let me tell you why.
When she goes even though
there's only 45 people at that
wedding or a hundred people at
that wedding or 200 people at
that wedding,
the media picks up on it and
gives her millions at scale.
And so what people are
misunderstanding is that when
you do authentic deep
engagement, the market rewards
you for it and you
actually get scale.
- But that's hard to fake.
You gotta be authentic you got
to be genuine when you do it.
So,--
- It's no different.
It's no different than the guy
asked in the other room he goes,
"Well how do you
become a thought leader?"
By being a thought leader.
You're right, it's hard.
It's hard to be authentic.
So how do you be authentic?
By being authentic.
You know, listen I always used
to say this, it's like doing
push-ups. You and I if we want
muscles you have to do push-ups.
You can't read about
the doing push-ups.
You can't outsource doing the
push-ups and so there's a reason
that people who are authentic
and actually doing are winning.
Because everybody else is trying
to figure out the shortcut.
- Ah, but it's interesting.
You talk about all this new
technology and you're also
talking about some
very traditional values.
- Because I believe technology
is the gateway drug
to traditional.
- Hmmmm.
- I believe what I do here
allows me to get to the moment
where if you watched me, all
the stuff he recorded, all those
handshakes, all those selfies,
it was all the work I did here
that got to the moment where
I got to shake his hand
and take that picture.
So I use technology
to scale the intimacy.
- And that pays off in
terms of more business.
- I think so.
Sure, I mean look, think about
who you're willing
to do things for.
It starts with your family
then it's your best friends,
then it's your friends,
then it's your acquaintances,
then it's strangers.
- Sure.
- I'm trying to close it.
- So you're making
the world smaller.
- 100% by putting in the work.
- [Gabrielle] And then you have
more customers comes to you.
- Absolutely and to me, if
you're really smart, the way
I think of it and this is very
important I make the world
smaller for
potential customers,
not customers.
That's a very
important distinction.
If you were to do things with
the intent to cash in on it,
you will lose.
Because the other
person will taste it.
The reason my stuff works is the
same reason when you asked me
why don't you tell me what to
tell the conservative business
people why they should hire you.
I don't want to.
I don't like to sell.
I like to guilt and leverage
people into being interested.
- [Gabrielle] But that's
interesting, you describe
yourself as a hustler.
- I am.
- [Gabrielle] As
a wine salesman.
- I am.
I think the best salespeople
in the world are the ones that
don't sell that are the ones
that actually have people coming
to them to buy.
And there's only one way to do
that, provide upfront value with
zero expectation in
return on a micro level.
On a macro level, I expect
it turning out to being good.
- But on the individual--
- Correct.
Correct, so if I give you 50
interviews, a business advice,
a tip on a stock, pick up your
daughter at a abandoned house in
New Jersey and I ask you
for something small--
- That was weird.
- That was very weird.
I have no idea but
I'm trying to go extreme.
- Yeah.
- If I do so much for you and
I ask for a little bit in return
and you say no, I'm unphased.
I think most people are phased.
Most people give and do
expect something in return.
I think the reason I'm
winning is 'cause I don't.
I just don't.
I know it works out but
I'm empathetic to know
sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes people want from
you and don't want to give and
that's okay because you
will win on a macro level.
I genuinely believe that.
- I should know this but how do
you make the bulk of your money?
What's the most profitable?
- My life is broken up into Wine
Library kicks me dividends each
year because it's still
owned family business.
Speaking I do very well in that
but much the far majority my
money is my salary and the
distribution of profits of
VaynerMedia which is really what
I do for a living and then you
know luckily occasionally some
of my companies
I invest in sell or go public.
I have big events.
Right, when Twitter went public.
When Facebook went public.
When Buddy Media was bought
by Salesforce so that's it.
But I'm also very investing in
my world meaning I can make a
lot more money from VaynerMedia
if I just stayed a 500 employees
instead of 800 this year,
I would've made a lot of money
but I'm reinvesting in myself.
- Because you're long term.
You mentioned your
venture capital company
on top of the media company.
- Yes.
- Is that real or is
it a future project?
- Venture is already happening.
What I mentioned was
private equity, buying brands,
it's very real.
It's the only reason
I built VaynerMedia.
To build a business that was
client services would've not
been interesting to me.
They're just not
good businesses.
- And this applies to anything,
anything you want to sell,
anything you want to do you
should have a media/content part.
- I think so.
I think so.
That's why I built it.
- [Woman] Last question.
- No problem.
Yes, and that's why I built it
because remember right now
I'm still hungry and on fire
and I want to buy the
New York Jets but I've hopefully
another 60 years in my life and
here's what's gonna
happen in those 60 years.
My kids are gonna grow
up and have interests.
I'm gonna lose family
and friends to diseases.
Something will happen at a macro
geopolitical level that scares
me and so not only do I want a
marketing machine to sell the
bubblegum brand that I buy and
flip it or to buy at an American
football team but if my mother
dies from a rare disease that's
not been cured, I'm gonna want
to use that machine to build
awareness and to find a cure.
If my daughter becomes
infatuated with volcanoes I want
to use that marketing machine to
give her the best position to do
what she wants in her life.
If my grandson wants to do X,
Y, and Z I want that marketing
machine to give him the best
chance to do that and so I think
it's a very important machine
to have for the rest of my life.
- Interesting so it doesn't
really matter if you never get
to buy the Jets anyway.
- Just the process to buy them.
To me the journey is way more
interesting than
the finish line.
- Interesting.